if you look at that polygamous societies
one of the things that they see that's
prevalent is there's a lot of like great
there's a lot of crime because
in polygamous societies the strongest
men take all the women which these other
men to revolt and cause problems so
monogamy is actually beneficial to say
it keeps women safe it makes Society by
and large more better nuclear family
homes lead to less
um
traumatic experiences for children so
you can see there's a lot of benefits
through marriage um so yeah there's
all right but you'd actually don't
really answer the question like why you
want to get mad you why you want to
again it's a beautiful thing okay you
already said that beautiful yes
the core advantage over that being in a
situation where you're not married yes
so why would like War so it's more
beneficial for kids
the point I was trying to get her is if
like if you have a reason for why you
want to get married they don't and you
believe in marriage and the vows that
you've made whether it's to God or
wherever then why would you then go
against those vows and cheat and then
it's for some reason it's okay first of
all I've been cheated no no I'm just
because the guys have left and they were
here before he's gonna ask them no no I
hear what you're saying but
I hate what you're trying to do I hate
what you're trying to say but you have
to remember and we've mentioned this
before that married although marriage is
what sought after and it's more
beneficial for our Offspring one the
reason I seek marriage is because it's
better for my kids to be raising a
nuclear family but even though it's
still it's still it's marriage is still
not my biological imperative I have to
sacrifice elements of mice biological
being to conform to the female standard
if I had my way I'd have my woman that I
love and it's women that just chop now
and again if I had my way but to conform
to the social standards of society
I try to be in a monogamous situation I
don't aspire to be a man that cheats
however anything that hasn't happened
it's just a prediction of the future to
get what I'm saying yeah and I think
most people put it that way so I'm just
saying this look if you've got a good
man
and he steps out once in like once or
twice in 40 years listen the grass isn't
green until you water it the grass ain't
green on the other side so I think
that's the thing that women have to
recognize does that work both ways of
course not
um
because men can love multiple women at
the same time or women can only love my
own man and if she's cheated if she's
cheating on you you don't love him no
but you you use an example yeah could
you just walk out now see a guy that
you're attracted to and say listen go
[__] me in the corner right now could
you do that so could you could you do
that for me personally I couldn't most
women most women couldn't yeah so most
people don't want to behave like that
you see a man if he sees a girl he's
attracted to you I will bang you in the
bush I'll bang in the street corner I
bang you know yeah it don't matter it is
what it is but that's the that's the
fundamental difference so so why it
can't be flipped around is because it
takes more food to allow someone in
whereas for a man it's like taking a
piss so that's why it's different but
why is it acceptable no I don't think
you get what I'm trying to say why is he
accepted no because is if if a woman
cheats yeah there's a reason behind why
she's cheating of course so then why is
it that if she cheats you can't just
accept it it's because it goes beyond
sex there's the emotions involved that
for women to let a guy in there's a
process it's premeditated it's never
just a slip up for a man it's literally
I wasn't using my head and I had a nut
to bust and that's that's all it is but
for you it goes further than that okay
but what if it was a slip up if it was a
girl
imagine no that's not a slipper a man
bending you over a glass in your back
yeah she's on holidays that's
premeditated you've gone on that holiday
I want wanting to [__] her brother out
there
if you love a man if you love a man
you're not looking if you really love a
man you're not you're not looking at
anyone else you only see him I'm not
listening to what I'm saying I said if
you are in a situation where you're
married and your woman slipped up and
just one time she slept with someone
just on holiday you know what uh do you
know what you take us
and you're you're trying to use the
exception to that no that is because
most women wouldn't behave most women
aren't slipping up I'm giving a scenario
in that scenario I'd like to think but
it could never happen I would just fall
and die if I hear that my new system
will shut down I'll just get covered and
I'll pass away okay so would you take
her back I could not I couldn't because
you know what by look by by holistically
that's not how women behave so how am I
supposed to assume that this is just a
slip up and not something more how can I
make that I'm Helen I'm telling you I've
given you a situation no and I hear what
your situation is saying but I'm saying
as a man I can't assume that that is the
case I have to assuming that the answer
is no you wouldn't take it out no of
course not for example 100 because you
know because you should know that me
slipping up is literally just slipping
up you letting a man in it's not it's
not because you said it yourself you
couldn't just let a man slip into your
tongue like that I said me personally
and most women dating you and most women
in your situation but if he was dating
me you can't slip up like that I'm sorry
I'm saying I'm giving you an actual
scenario where she slipped up she went
on holiday she had a hot girl oh yeah
and then she just had a bit too much to
drink one thing led to another she just
one night stand or I didn't it meant
nothing it was just a slip up
and then would you take her back yeah
can I just say that can I just say that
women cheat right women she it got it's
just it got nothing to do with life I
understand that when women oh then when
men cheat it's a one-off when we mean
she the relationship is finished
think that you've I agree and 100 now
what I'm trying to say is that how many
women
are the ever woman cheats she knows that
the relationship is finished
nine times out of ten if the woman
cheats that's the end of it that's the
end of her relationship that's true but
as ever man sheets it's not the end or
to put it as my mum will say it
men have all their bits on the outside
because they can flick it around
everywhere God hid the women's away
because it's hard to find internally so
if you're gonna go and give it away like
that there's a lot to go through for a
man to get to you internally rather just
on the outside because women are The
Gatekeepers of sex or even more but even
more than that you have to think but the
point guys is like it's not about the
man which is coming back and every time
we know that you're probably gonna sleep
around and come back home the point is
what about us like how do we do you
think that not actually you know
as an impact on your marriage do you
think she gonna be fine no knewing that
you actually eat other okay
and you're sleeping next to me man I'm
not saying they wouldn't pay me yes so
and so you actually prefer like yeah and
do you think they're good
men and women aren't the same yeah
I know but you're making everything
about it
I told you I explained you uh over
talking me stop over talking me again
again stop over talking me stop over
talking me no no no no stop stop you can
go after I'm done okay it men and women
aren't the same and so a man can have
sex with a hole in the wall they don't
care a woman a woman if she sleeps with
some a man he has to be someone we are
not sleeping with bums out there unless
she looks like Michael B Jordan that is
it I get that so again I'm like I asked
everyone individually would you get
married and why I asked him individually
would you take a woman back if she
slipped up and it was just a one and
done thing and it was Michael B Jordan
and it was like she had a chance to
would you take her back no no but but if
you did it and you slept with a random
whatever she can take you back
a woman ain't gonna sleep with a random
amount
I'm asking as an individual not
generalizing Okay so
should a woman take a man back if he
cheats no she shouldn't does she yes
that is not our choice as we are saying
men and women are different if you speak
to women I've spoken to a lot of women
yeah and when they say to me are
um my relationship ended because my man
was cheating yeah the first thing I say
to them is what did he cheat once and
then you left and they said no he was
cheating is never he cheated it's always
he was cheating which meant this dude
has decided he is going to continue
sleeping with other women but when did
she find out it was women no one and
then it was oh no no no no no my point
is you're not going to go out and find a
woman who says I went I was going out
with this dude he cheated on me once and
I left you don't it doesn't happen if
women if women don't like being cheated
yeah exactly even so yeah even though on
your point yeah
if I was to take this woman back do you
think she'll ever respect me so you
she's gonna go she's gonna go sit on the
next man's face for banner and what a
woman's a look a man no no no no no if
if you because you have to remember a
lot of relationships are predicated on
on respect yeah if you've lost that
respect for me enough to step out
it's gone because you have to think
about in relationships the only time the
relationship's truly done is when the
woman says it's done the man can say
it's not gonna come back a week later
babes listen I'm sorry his dick's hard
he wants to do something you see when a
woman says she's done there's no return
end of end of so for a woman to do that
image is done you know I'm saying and
for a man the most egregious crime he
can commit is is this loyalty there's no
there's no bigger crime
may I come back to your point you said
uh I never ate about you know how women
say uh he cheated once yeah you're right
because man doesn't [__] one if it's if
he's cheat once he's gonna come back to
again again again so man doesn't cheat
once in a while or once in his life it's
just if it is going there it's gonna
come back
do you ever ask why he cheated
a lot of times like girls don't give
their guys sex and are confused when
they trust me trust me I've been there
at that point
okay 25 of marriages